[Music]
you guys sound good tonight
thank you yeah that's very nice see the
commercials they play songs that are
really famous right we can't afford to
pay for right and then when we come just
as we're coming back to commercial they
transition and it just sounds like any
right exactly a song we don't have to
pay right right we save hundreds of
dollars only and these people get to
enjoy verified it's yeah you guys are
playing a little Tom Petty right
American girl during the commercial
break or I'm not allowed to even say
that what has it worked am I not allowed
to even say that yeah I can say that
during the commercial break they were
playing Tom Petty's American girl right
yeah but everyone loves that song and
prices were coming back it's like you
know we were in a Mara Wow yeah and
that's the part that's on television
right we pay nothing that's right
sorry Tom Petty yeah Tom Petty fu you
know when we're not on camera we play
your music all the time
yeah for free it's great in our audience
loves me yeah hey in the next commercial
break let's play Led Zeppelin that
stuff's really expensive no one yeah so
when we start to go to break just be
like and then the second we're off
camera a spy he stay away if you say too
many words you'll have to pay for him I
didn't say stairway to what oh that's
right
stairway to the bathroom on the second
floor should Ching $0 all right well I
just let you into our process people
love behind the scenes you know this did
nothing because I did it into a
microphone I know
you